welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and obi-wan episode 3 went full
episode 3 and gave us the revenge of the
sith lord vader as he beat an old nanny
senseless and dragged him through some
hot rocks atop some coarse rough and
irritating sand the worst fate a man can
go through but like if darth vader
clearly had the advantage over a
seemingly washed up obi-wan kenobi why
didn't anakin just kill his old master
right then and there like why the hell
did darth vader let obi-wan kenobi live
well let's speculate all this together
my nerd babies because i think this all
has to do with a core tenet of the sith
ideology a little something called fear
you heard of it it's that feeling that
you experience when you miss out on our
newest latest obsession shirt inspired
by obi-wan kenobi make sure to pick one
of them up at newrockstarsmerch.com
because they're not going to last
forever and just pick one up so you can
wear one as you watch obi-wan together
with your family your whole family can
own one at the same time it's possible
this video is brought to you by
squarespace the all-in-one platform for
building your brand more on them later
alright so episode 3 of obi-wan kenobi
has a darth vader playing around with
his food after apparently having been
searching for obi-wan kenobi for a very
long time lord vader will be pleased
he's been looking for you for a long
time and this would make sense
considering that obi-wan is directly
responsible for the iconic darth vader
suit that we all know and love to fear
as it was during their last bro session
on the planet mustafar that obi-wan
would do a dooku and chop off an anakin
limb or two or three and then leave
those limbs barbecuing next to the
crispy grumpy stump of a mannequin sky
crawler that used to be anakin skywalker
making his new black suit very much
necessary for anakin to even live and i
believe that this is the very reason why
darth vader interacts with obi-wan
kenobi in the weird way that he does
during their long-awaited reunion in
this episode like it's not just about
killing obi-wan kenobi for darth vader
like much like he says in this episode
it's all about seeing obi-wan kenobi
suffer in a very specific way before he
is killed and i believe that the moment
vader decides to do this comes when he
sees obi-wan's fearful reaction to him
with his red lightsaber drawn
now yeah i do think that vader actually
did go down to this planet to fight and
kill his old master to not only have his
revenge for his disfigurement but to
also prove to his old master that he was
now superior to him in every way you
know despite all those years of obi-wan
and the evil jedi council holding him
back from greatness as he saw it it's
all obi-wan's full
he's jealous
he's holding me back however i believe
the moment cyborg mannequin saw obi-wan
obi run away unwilling to use his glowy
obi wand on his former brobee wong vader
realized just how much his old master
has been crippled by fear this entire
time during his exile a fear that is
expertly captured might i add through
extremely clever first-person camera
shots mimicking the wild movements of a
paranoid obi-wan kenobi's head but it's
not just obi-wan's fear of a rageful
death at the hand of darth vader that
causes him to run away from this tall
angry man but also just confronting his
own failure with his iconic line from
revenge of the sith having rung in his
head this entire time he's been in exile
ever since their fateful duel at the
lava pits i have failed you anakin
i have failed you darth vader being the
ultimate sith lord of fear knows that
this is obi-wan's weakness right now
because the jedi have never really
taught any of them how to confront fear
only how to run away from it because
remember that famous yoda quote fear is
the path to the dark side
fear leads to anger anger leads to hate
hate
leads to suffering and all of this is
what the jedi believed would lead one to
the dark side of the force however as
one luke skywalker would come to learn
at the end of his long life running away
from fear and studying the sacred jedi
texts the jedi council were completely
wrong to preach a doctrine as imbalanced
and impractical as complete fear
avoidance because as luke skywalker
would tell rey in episode 9 confronting
fear is the destiny of a jedi like as
much as anakin skywalker tried to run
from his fear of death and loss as
stoked by the death of his wife and
mother as much as luke skywalker tried
to run from his fear of confronting his
nephew that he had let down and hell
even as much as yoda tried to run from
his fear of training a skywalker in the
first place each and every one of these
jedi were forced to confront their fear
in the end and that is what makes them
heroes which is why rey is awarded the
title of skywalker at the end of the
rise of skywalker when she walked the
jedi path by facing the fear of
confronting palpatine and her own pal
potential because she had that palpatine
blood running through her veins and she
could have been as evil as her
grandpappy look if you hate your job or
maybe you hate not having a job then
maybe you can make 2022 the year that
you start your own business squarespace
is the all-in-one platform to build a
beautiful online presence for that new
business you want a website that
projects that you know what you're doing
and squarespace does just that
squarespace has a bunch of great
features to help your business be
successful you can present members only
gated content create email campaigns or
add online booking for appointments or
sessions all from the squarespace
interface i really dig the analytics
section of a squarespace website where
you can dig into what's working and what
you should be doing more of head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain thanks again to
squarespace for sponsoring this video
this all being said darth vader just
wants obi-wan kenobi to feel fear and he
also wants him to physically suffer the
way that obi-wan made him suffer which
is why he specifically chooses to light
rocks on fire to drag his former master
through much like obi-wan watched him
crawl through the hot rocks of lucifer
anakin's goal here is to make obi-wan's
fear push him towards the dark side to
snuff out any last bits of the light
inside of obi-wan before vader feels
happy enough to just let him die the
sith just revel in their own power and
then use that power to stoke fear and
others so they can manipulate that fear
to destroy their targets from within
much like palpatine did with the entire
jedi order as one master yoda would
reveal to ezra bridger in star wars
rebels thousands of jedi once there were
consumed by the dark side the jedi were
consumed by fear that was
although see it i did not you were
afraid
yes
afraid
surprised are you basically vader wants
to make sure obi-wan goes through hell
in this life before he sends him on to
the next line because this is basically
the vengeful and cruel way of the sith
but i am confident that it will be
through this very show that we learn
just how obi-wan discovered how to
conquer his fear of confronting darth
vader that he would of course ultimately
take with him during their final
confrontation in a new hope a lesson
that hopefully the force ghost of
qui-gon jinn will teach his former
padawan by series end you know if he
would just pick up the dank ferric force
ghost phone for once man come on liam
neeson help a brother out there is no
wifi in the desert and obi-wan kenobi
has two friends and one of them's a
ten-year-old and the other one is a
space camel but anyways that is why i
believe that darth vader did not kill
obi-wan kenobi at this time but he very
much wants to do that in the near future
but we all know that's not gonna happen
spoiler alert sorry but let us know what
you guys think of course in the comment
section below because we'll always love
to hear what you guys have to say but
thank you guys so much for watching this
video you can follow me mastertainment
on twitter if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] and insane theories even
more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media and when you do on youtube make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and hey if you want to
talk even more new rockstars nerdy
goodness but again thank you guys so
much for watching this video i love you
guys so so much i may the force be with
each and every one of you goodbye
[Music]
you